foreign
look at this thing this is the Oppo Find
X6 Pro now I've talked about oppo's find
X Series smartphones before they've made
some pretty wild stuff in the past this
X6 Pro is not even coming to the US it's
apparently going to be China only but
I've gotten actually use it for about a
week and it's got me thinking
smartphone Hardware has gotten so
ridiculously capable and this being at
the top of the Heap is so capable that I
think we might actually be taking it for
granted a little bit so okay let's back
up aesthetically slab smartphones have
all kind of started to look the same we
are all on the same page about that this
one actually kind of manages to spice it
up a little bit with this half vegan
leather on the bottom which kind of has
a little texture to it which is nice and
then the top half and the rails are like
this satin metal so it is a bit
different and I actually like it a lot
but you know that's the Apple find
series for you they've been really good
at spicing it up from the standard slab
formula for a number of years and they
try all sorts of interesting stuff there
are some solid colored versions of this
phone as well but this is the one that
really makes a statement but none of
that is even really what I'm talking
about in this video what I am talking
about is what's under the hood
get it under the hood because of the
Good hoodie anyway uh yeah under the
hood here so Chinese software aside I
can just tell that because this is a
Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 with 16 gigs of RAM
with fast storage and great other
supporting specs I feel pretty
comfortable saying that it's going to go
well but there are three main areas just
that I just want to appreciate with
smartphone Hardware capability right now
so the first one is the battery now okay
here's the way we normally think of
smartphone battery right like what was a
good smartphone battery life like eight
nine ten years ago it's like oh all day
if it could last all for an entire day
of battery life that'd be pretty good
now fast forward all the way to 2023 and
what what is a good smartphone battery
life it's it's one day all of a day
maybe two days if you're lucky so it
doesn't feel like it's it's Advanced
that much but of course you need to
consider the amount of stuff our
smartphones are doing has gotten way
more dramatic much more powerful
processing bigger screens way more
radios these things are way more power
hungry so for those older smartphones
and all-day battery life meant having
like a 2000 to 3 000 milliamp hour
battery and then even as recently as
like three years ago
you could either get like a 5 000
milliamp hour battery with slower
charging or you could get like a 3000
milliamp hour battery and have blazing
fast charging but now it's 2023 we can
have both now this one's got a 5 000
milliamp hour battery that also charges
at a hundred Watts wired or even 50
watts wireless charging so with a cable
that 100 Watts will do zero to 100 in 30
minutes but even through what they're
calling air vook wireless charging
because I got to name everything with
the right accessory you can get 50
charge in 22 minutes on the wireless
charger so it's kind of sick plus
there's all the battery extras and modes
to ideally help keep the battery healthy
and optimized so that you can fast
charge as much as you want without
damaging a thing it learns your schedule
does that whole dance this one even has
an ultra low temperature charging mode I
think any phone could probably have this
mode if they programmed it but basically
what this phone is doing is if it
detects you're in extreme cold like 0 to
negative 25 degrees Celsius so it's your
freeze it's it's Canada in the middle of
the winter something crazy and so it's
really cold the battery's really cold
but batteries need to be in a certain
temperature range to charge quickly like
somewhere around room temperature so if
you plug it in in that extreme coal then
it needs to rapidly charge it will
actually run an artificial load through
the computer through the processor like
basically Benchmark itself over and over
again to start to generate heat in the
computer to warm up the phone to get the
battery to a better temperature to
charge quickly so even at the end of the
day if it's still you know if it was 10
years ago all-day battery life and now
today it's still all-day battery life I
still think it's way more impressive now
than it was back then so that's number
one the battery then number two is this
display so you know watching this
through a compression through a website
on YouTube video and then on the screen
of your phone you won't be able to tell
how awesome this screen is like you'll
just see another phone with thin bezels
and some slightly curved edges and a
hole punch cut out for the selfie camera
looking
pretty normal I remember not that long
ago when we were first getting retina
displays and smartphones we were getting
basically right over the 300 pixels per
inch 300 PPI limit where you can't
really discern individual pixels anymore
that was back in the like iPhone 4S days
where it was like a 60 hertz flat LCD
but it was like oh it's a retina display
but this screen this display here on a
smartphone this is a 6.82 inch diagonal
with a 3168 by 1440 resolution that's
510 pixels per inch for anybody counting
razor sharp but you can turn it down to
1080p anytime it's also an AMOLED
display with ltpo so it goes all the way
up to 120 hertz and all the way down to
1 Hertz when it doesn't need to be
moving at all to be efficient and it has
a 240Hz touch sample rate it's extremely
responsive to the touch whether it's
scrolling or swiping around or gaming it
also has adjustable color settings to
get it looking exactly dialed the way
you want and by the way it has a max
Peak brightness of 2 500 nits so there's
pretty much no situation whether it's in
the dash of your car or outdoors in
direct sunlight there's no situation
where it's not bright enough to be
readable which is dope all while housing
a pretty standard really quick Optical
fingerprint sensor and the hole punch
camera you saw with the cutout for the
selfie camera at the top do I wish it
was more flat yeah if I was gonna daily
this phone I'd want a more flat display
than this but I mean this is the Oppo
Find X thing that's what they always do
they try to go a little fancy a little
spicy with the hardware so I almost give
it a pass because I expected that but
this display is world class it's hard to
appreciate on the camera but if you show
this display or those numbers because
people eight nine years ago it would be
nuts
so that's two then three is the camera I
mean you look at a phone like this and
it's pretty clear what the focus is
that's fun but the camera system on the
backs of these phones has swelled up
more and more over the years especially
on the flagships at this point it's damn
near half the back of the phone this one
is a triple camera setup so one standard
one Ultra wide and one Periscope Zoom
now those first two categories display
and Battery are less software dependent
like you can basically brute force your
way into having a good one if you just
buy a good enough part like you don't
need good software to have a great
display just buy a good display and
optimization helps but like if you buy a
huge battery you'll have a pretty good
battery life
but cameras are a little different
cameras as we talked about are mostly I
mean it's a lot of software work that
goes into determining the character of
the photos and videos you get out of a
smartphone camera it's basically a
computer
and so in order to separate yourself at
the very top of smartphone cameras
something like this like a flagship
actually needs to combine the two if you
want to give your software the best
chance of succeeding you need to give it
the best information possible and so
this is trying to do both so let's not
even worry about the megapixel count but
just the sheer size of the sensors in
here and their light Gathering abilities
and then the quality of the lenses
they're able to fit in front of them
this is a primary camera that is a 50
megapixel one inch type sensor with
Optical stabilization and a 1.8 aperture
and so while it still has to be oppo's
software that does all the processing
that is most of the work in creating a
photo nowadays it absolutely makes a big
difference to give that computer as much
light and as much information as
possible so that's what's going on the
biggest thing is that these huge sensors
tend to struggle with is actually
minimum Focus distance and close-up
subjects so thankfully this system also
has a massive 1 over 1.56 inch Ultra
wide sensor with an F 2.2 aperture and
it also happens to have a four
centimeter minimum Focus system so you
can take close-up shots and it's got
this built-in macro mode to handle most
of the weaknesses of the primary camera
and there's a matching identical
actually large sensor behind the 3x
Periscope camera and that one also has
an F 2.6 aperture so they are all 50
megapixel cameras they can also all do a
2X crop and still be very detailed so
that kind of makes it feel like the 1X
camera is now a 1X and a 2X and the 3x
camera is both a 3X and a 6X but then
you'll know Samsung phones will go to
the extra mile and also include a 10x
camera which can also crop if you want
to so they'll go like as much Zoom
versatility as possible but the point is
yeah we're throwing Hardware at it now
and it works it's important still camera
systems like this were just kind of not
on the radar a few years ago especially
because designs wouldn't really allowed
it like we just kind of got used to
gigantic bumps on the back of phones so
the downside or maybe upside depending
on how you see it is phones today just
have bigger and bigger camera bumps on
the back to house all these massive
sensors and big Optics but this one I
actually don't really mind maybe you
feel the same way they've embraced the
Hasselblad branding obviously they also
put this whole thing in a huge circle
and then it has this nice knurled ring
around the camera Circle that reminds me
of those like nice especially Hasselblad
cameras it's got the dot in the middle
which is typically where you'd line up a
lens to put it on so it kind of It kind
of plays it well it looks fine also
there's a couple phones with like huge
camera bumps where I like that the
bottom of it is right in the spot that
matches where my finger rests on the
back of the phone so I actually use the
camera bump to hold up the back of the
phone comfortably and this is one of
them this phone also happens to have the
fastest storage we've seen in Android
phones it's ufs 4.0 storage has the
fastest Ram has the fastest Wi-Fi as
Wi-Fi 7 capable it also has fantastic
haptics all of that is enabled by
hardware and this isn't even really the
most powerful smartphone out like let's
be honest it's going to be the gaming
phones again that level up this chipset
give it crazy cooling like overclock it
they'll do nuts things they'll
prioritize different things they'll have
a higher refresh rate screen they'll
have big front-facing speakers and
things like that others might prioritize
design in a way that's like extra thin
different phones do different things and
that's not even touching the whole
battle being fought over how folding
phone form factors should work because
there are a lot of options out there and
that is all hardware and that is all
still very interesting but just as far
as the standard slab smartphone these
these pieces of Hardware would be like
Unthinkable eight seven six years ago so
that's pretty cool
thanks for watching catch you guys the
next one peace
[Music]